is jordan peel's newest feature film
boring or straightforward nope the film
packs a lot of spectacle heart and
thematic meaning into its run time
here's the ending of nope explained
nope spans roughly six months most of
which we don't even see it begins with
the death of otis haywood senior when a
piece of metal shoots into his brain the
authorities blame a freak accident for
this but six months later his children
oj and emerald develop a different
theory a ufo is responsible and their
father's death is part of a larger
pattern of violence what's especially
significant about this six month time
period in the context of the larger
story of course is that we simply don't
know exactly how much chaos the ufo
caused in those missing months between
otis senior's death and his children
discovering what's really going on
whatever else happens in nope one thing
is clear the real toll of the events of
the film is likely much higher than what
we see it's a bad miracle
o.j haywood is living with trauma that
he's reluctant to address he witnessed
the death of his father at the very
beginning of the film and spends the
rest of nope trying to keep the family's
horse ranch alive and kicking for much
of the film he seems to be quietly
failing in that effort and the reminders
of his father are never very far away
over the course of the film we see
several flashbacks in which oj recalls
lessons from his father about life and
horse training lessons that he's then
later able to apply to hunting the ufo
and ultimately surviving it by the end
of the film as the dust is literally
settling o.j emerges as a survivor of
something that claimed his father's life
succeeding in his own way at something
his father never got a chance to master
in some ways o.j has just performed the
ultimate feat of animal wrangling
growing beyond his father in the process
though she claims to be busy emerald
haywood is someone on the hunt for
greatness when the ufo begins to menace
the ranch she thinks she's maybe found
her shot a moment that can propel her to
something bigger and a chance at
achieving her dreams of course once she
convinces oj to go along with her plan
emerald finds she's in way over her head
particularly when certain family
resentments start to creep back in for
emerald this is a chance to make the
family business about her for a change
when everything starts to go sideways it
challenges her view of what her family
is strengthens her bond with her brother
and most importantly forces emerald to
realize her true strength in ways she
never did before when her brother names
the ufo jean jacket after the horse her
father took from her emerald takes on
the responsibility of finally finishing
the struggle getting the shot and even
defeating the entity by the end she's
come into her own
when their own efforts to capture the
ufo on film turn up short o.j and
emerald turn to antlers holst a famous
cinematographer they met once on a
commercial shoot who was intrigued by
the challenge of photographing such a
strange object eventually lured out to
the ranch antlers even builds a
completely manual camera to get around
the ufo's ability to disrupt anything
with a battery making sure he's more
likely than anyone to get the thing on
film
in the end antlers does manage to
capture footage of the ufo but he also
ends up so driven by his own desire to
do the impossible that he takes his
portable camera and deliberately goes
into the belly of the beast sacrificing
himself for the sake of his art the
question now of course is whether or not
any of that art survived both cameras
were destroyed in one way or another by
the ufo and we saw at least one film
canister unspooling as it rolled down
the hill but there's at least one film
magazine unaccounted for and we don't
know what happened to antler's other
film as he went up into the creature
it's possible that his real legacy will
be restored salvaged footage of the ufo
his last great cinematic achievement
o.j and emerald also get a hand from
angel a curious and conspiracy loving
employee at an electronics store who
comes out to set up their surveillance
equipment for them at first oj and
emerald want to keep angel at a distance
but over time he becomes a key part of
the operation by the end of the film
angel is caught up in the path of the
ufo to the point that he seems convinced
he's about to face his own death to
counteract that he wraps himself
partially in barbed wire hoping that the
sharp fencing will damage the ufo's
digestive tract and help him to get free
he's right the creature is indeed
wounded and angel falls down into the
desert still alive even if he is a
little battered the film doesn't show us
what happens to angel next but there's a
very good chance that he'll spend the
rest of his life telling anyone who will
listen about what he experienced
regardless of whether or not he's got
proof the film's greatest ufo evangelist
has finally seen the truth and there's
no way he's letting that go
maybe you're in a ufo hot spot in the
film's climax emerald rides to the
closed jupiter's claim theme park doing
her best to lure the ufo along with her
in the hope that she can use the camera
at the bottom of the wishing well to
capture one last image her plan pays off
as she uses a giant jupe balloon to lure
the ufo into the frame takes the picture
then watches as the balloon pops and
destroys the ufo creature in the process
as she declares victory emerald takes a
moment to rest on the ground in the
middle of the theme park only to realize
she's not alone news crews who were
there to cover the mass disappearances
at the park are just outside the gates
and if they didn't see the whole thing
unfolding then they at least saw part of
it so did any of them get footage are
they going to steal emerald's thunder
are they going to believe her when she
tells her story one thing's for sure
they're not about to just abandon the
story as it's getting interesting
after spending much of the film building
up his new show at the theme park jup
finally reveals what he's been working
on in one of the film's most memorable
sequences the new star lasso experience
at jupiter's claim is actually the ufo
itself which jup has been watching for
six months learning its behaviors so he
can lure it out to become a public
spectacle that plan backfires
spectacularly because jup misunderstands
how the ufo hunts and he and his entire
audience are killed when the creature
descends sucks them all into the sky and
devours them while he doesn't get
everything right in attempting to
harness the power of the ufo it's clear
that jupe has been watching it for some
time and planning a show around it so
who did he tell other than his wife and
perhaps his staff who are also all dead
now is anyone else out there aware of
what jup was doing and willing to talk
about it does the ufo have a wider
sphere of influence than the film might
lead us to believe the answer isn't
clear but the investigation likely won't
stop with jup's death
the opening shot of nope is a seemingly
incongruous shot of a bloodied
chimpanzee on a tv set sitting next to
what seems to be a dead human body later
in the film we learned that this is
gordy the chimp star of jup's second
major hollywood outing a sitcom called
gordy's house
during the shoot one day a popping
balloon set gordy off and he attacked
his human co-stars seemingly killing two
of them before turning his attention to
jew jupe who was hiding under a table is
terrified until he realized the chimp
actually just wants to do their
trademark fist bump a sign of the bond
they share
before he can re-establish that bond
though jupe watches as gordy is gunned
down by first responders though he tries
to play it off in adulthood gordy's
death plainly had a major impact on juke
who takes some of that unresolved
emotion and brings it to bear on the ufo
if he could connect with a homicidal
chimp he thinks he can connect with a
ufo in the sky he's wrong of course in
keeping with otis senior's lesson that
some animals just don't want to be tamed
it's a key part of jup's character that
he's convinced he can do it and an
enlightening subplot in the overall saga
of the ufo
throughout the film emerald and oj talk
regularly about getting
the shot the money shot undeniable
singular
the oprah shot this is an image of the
ufo so impressive that even oprah
winfrey will want to feature them on
television all of their early attempts
from phones to surveillance cameras fail
in this effort and even antlers attempts
to get the thing on film with a
mechanical camera
may have come up short when his film was
put through the ringer
still with help from the wishing well
camera at jupiter's claim emerald makes
the oprah shot happen pulling off a
beautiful shot of the creature just as
it swallows the juke balloon she sent up
into the sky but emerald managed to get
an impressive shot to share with the
world is not in question what's perhaps
more important at that moment is what it
costs her to get it she's lost friends
horses much of the family farm and
nearly her brother and her own life to
get the oprah shot and now we're left
wondering was it worth it it's a lasting
question that nope asks about every
major spectacle visited throughout the
film from tv shows to carnival
attractions
in the final moments of note emerald
stands up in the middle of jupiter's
claim and looks out into the distance
she catches her breath for a moment
closes her eyes and when she opens them
again she smiles
the camera shows us oj and his horse
lucky standing just outside the gates
that lead to the parks arena then the
film ends nope is a fairly
straightforward easy to follow film but
for the sake of covering all the bases
it's worth at least entertaining the
possibility that oj died and that
emerald is just seeing her brother
through pure hope oj doesn't make a move
to interact with her in this scene nor
is he even moving his horse and the sign
just above him says out yonder which
could be a nod in the direction of the
great beyond much of the main arc of the
film is about emerald growing up and
learning to handle things on her own
without her father or her brother and in
killing the ufo she achieves that maybe
this is the film's way of telling us
she's now moving beyond her family and
into something or maybe oj's just
standing there waiting to give her a
ride back to the ranch given the way the
finale is staged it's probably up to
audiences to make up their own minds
so what happens next during his opening
remarks at the star lasso experience jup
describes the ufo which he presumes to
be an alien spacecraft and explains that
he's taken to calling the aliens the
viewers it's a brief mention but it's
also a clue into the larger symbolism at
work in the film
oj and emerald work in the film industry
jup is a former child star who's become
a theme park promoter in other words
their entire lives are built in some way
around getting viewers to pay attention
to them whether it's on a stage or in
movies or just in a commercial attention
is a key part of their economy and now
they've attracted the attention of a
viewer in the ufo that is a seemingly
relentless unreasoning consumer of
content
it doesn't care what you want or who you
are if you're looking at it it's looking
back at you ready to eat you alive by
calling the ufo a viewer peel has made a
fascinating point about the nature of
spectacle our human sense of curiosity
and what we're doing when we treat other
people as an other to be observed it's a
great metaphor in the middle of a
thoroughly entertaining film check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you